hi guys I'm Carly from New meteor rock
stars and I'm sitting down with Amy Lee
Lucas hello and we're going to be
talking about her new adventures with
when it counts so how did you kind of
get into when it counts and start doing
this production and how's everything
going right now um what accounts is so
exciting I love lon food production team
up with a tts the best thing that
happened um I was asked to be involved
in it when filled had called me I had no
idea what it was going to be about and
it was quite an adventure I'm very very
fond of entering so are you guys in the
middle of filming right now I know that
filming takes place on all of the
comments that are coming in so it seems
like a really quick production process
to turn everything around all the time
whew that is a really good question um I
think we kind of filmed everything
already like a few months ago maybe a
month ago time flies and who knows I
think if enough people comments and want
a different change in the story may get
together make it happen oh cool can you
give us a little preview are the things
to expect from it absolutely oh it's
really cool because Phil's been doing
the whole step by step episodes and so
for all of us to get into one place
under one roof and to be acting like
this is my first time acting me and it's
about a dance troupe and all the drama
happens at a space within it and who
likes who so you know you hear about
love triangles I think this may be a
love square mm-hmm um dos and my
character is Anna I it's really fun
plager because i get to step out of the
box and be a little meeting a little
flirty little nice so that was really
fun cool well i was watching the first
episode and anna's she's kind of a
heartbreaker I'm not gonna lie the group
what how did you relate to her did you
like find similarities when you were
playing her and how did you come like
develop her in series that is an awesome
question
um I feel like the majority of the
audience and I want say everyone but I
feel like most of us have been there
where we have a really good close friend
and you just don't see anything intimate
happening with them you love that
relationship the way it is and you don't
want to jeopardize that by I don't know
becoming a boyfriend/girlfriend
situation so that's what Anna had to do
which I got a lot of comments on Twitter
especially like why do that to subway I
was like no he's awesome as ever and I'm
doing it to him hey you guys know
Anthony Lee mm-hmm awesome awesome guy
great friend and because my character is
a flirtatious one he too I guess help
his roll out he says we had a thing in
the past well needs well how have you
how has it been transitioning into
acting because you've done so much with
the dance community and you're so
involved in LA was a different going
into acting and would you want to pursue
it later on um acting is awesome there's
a different kind of I guess everything
and I was really scared to be honest um
I don't have any acting experience but
Wong foo was so great favorite coach is
they really took their time to make sure
that we were in character that we knew
exactly what we're doing and what kind
of um I guess what kind of emotions we
have to play and I put out there you'll
see that Yuri um Yuri and I got into it
and I I'm psyched it's my own stunts so
okay oh yeah that's a that's a cliff
hanger right there yes um but they were
so great they said they wouldn't move on
from another from one shot to another
unless it was done perfectly ok meet did
it take a lot of takes for because it
was a lot of dancer than this and I
don't
no if most of them this was all your
first time or yes for some of us and
Anthony Anthony is a goofball it was his
first time and it was great because long
crew it's like they have their sense of
humor okay and we tried to switch it on
when we have to act its jaw line and we
weren't rolling I guess we did take
couple takes and I think there would be
a whole four episodes of just bloopers
you know we good a lot of giggling
happening well I have to ask you have
you ever been friend-zoned and how did
you deal with that friends now um yes as
much as we are in the position of
rejecting a friend I think we also are
in position of being told to be put in
friend zone it's um I think it takes a
lot of guts and for someone to just tell
another person that they're interested
that they like them that they're
attracted to them and sometimes it works
in our favor and sometimes it doesn't so
yes I could find the friend zone and I
think sometimes it's for better like it
just wasn't meant to happen and I really
appreciate the friendship I have with
them so sister well do you think it was
the first question asked at the end of
episode 1 but do you think that nice
girls finish last yes i'm in different
cases like maybe not even in a
relationship sometimes nice girls or
nice guys we don't speak up you don't
say how we feel we don't say what we
watch out loud so sometimes we end up
finishing last and i think it's a good
medium time is being assertive and being
aggressive and at the same time being
nice okay well what are some things that
you're working on now I know that you
have the bum leg so the guy just kind of
slowing you down for a little bit yeah I
had an accident Saturday evening um and
I'm very fortunate because everyone is
very supportive and I have a lot of help
and I've never had stitches so this is
such a new experience on its own but um
stitches will heal attendees and okay I
have been working on 2013 and so I have
a lot of countries in line to take my
classes which are called MVP and teach
kpop overseas need so will you travel
over there do you kind of have a
scheduler yes you know is it's really a
dream of me mine it's a dream of mine to
take these classes um internationally
right now and for a longest time I
thought I was just going to keep it
level mm but um it's it's really big
it's exciting I get to go to philippines
or wherever it is and I'm touch fans out
there and I should be sticking to
schedule but the same time I'm like
really excited to go experience the
culture and to eat all the food I should
eat and then work out and dance and then
go back to eating some more yeah okay
why are you so passionate about this
certain type of dance and just spreading
it all around the world that's great
question and you know I started and I
worked in Korea for a while and I love
hip-hop it's such a catchy jiggy kind of
music and I've always loved that that's
um that's a guilty pleasure of mine and
now another there's so many people that
okay I say this a lot but I feel like
k-pop fans are kind of coming out of
closet I would say so I've had a lot of
friends admit it to me like in kind of
like quiet voices like Carly I've been
listening to this I'm like oh oh you can
tell me it's okay it sounds like all
right well it's out there now yes
exactly and so sometimes your friends or
people you go to church way their school
you never know and we end up loving kpop
and it's really cool because i feel like
i can create a platform but it mom I'll
come together make me friends talk about
who they love and it's it's intense and
the same
it's really fun because they're very
divided some people really love this
record label or some people of all the I
guess idols but um I to get to
experience being a teacher and like
doing girly movements and then being
like a boy so it's really fun needs and
I was watching an interview with you on
YouTube I forget the group but you
talked about you did ballet for 14 years
and that's like the opposite dance form
like it's so structured and how do you
feel like that's kind of like built a
foundation for you as a dancer ballet is
so important and I feel like I'm
thankful for all the years that my mom
put me through and forced me to go to UM
with everything like I feel like I have
a different kind of confidence or it
helps my posture it helps my dancing now
and it sucks at the same time I loved
hip-hop because it's so the opposite and
then when you're the other end of the
spectrum you get a good at one thing you
get bad the other and you have to like
do this balancing act so one of my first
shows and come out here to LA and become
a dancer you have to efficient and they
love freestyle so I'm freestyling I'm up
for apple ipod commercial mm-hmm and I'm
starting to my hip hop not an IV shinies
and like the boat doin LA but lo and
behold I would ask to come to the
callback and I get the job and so I
think it's really helped me how means
well in what ways do you think that
YouTube is really changing the dance
community do you think that it's opening
up new doors or do you think in a way
it's taking away from the live
performance YouTube is insane I think
it's a full movies sonic I know the
tackles new media is like something I'm
still reaching for it um YouTube is
great especially for dancers and
choreographers not only to improve
oneself and see and share and get
opinions um a lot of choreography
hers who have a following on YouTube
book a lot of jobs overseas so it's
really great because a lot of countries
have open their doors to have a u.s.
choreographer work for huge record
labels on emi orgy mmm so I think it's
opening opportunities um live shows
nothing beats live music more like
performances or stand up comedy I'm a
true fan of the Arts but um it is very
limited you get to perform for your
community and there's nothing like being
on stage you get one chance we're in a
YouTube video you can edit do it 20
million times so I hope it's not
checking away from it because I will go
and spend money to go watch a sir clive
vs in theater club every what are you
kind of taken away from when it counts
how do you think it's gonna affect your
dance do you think you'd want to get
back into acting again yeah what
accounts it's such an honor to be in the
room with peers and we'd want to and
with AT&T ATT products are amazing like
I had fun just playing okay actually
like oh I just don't see my picture um
but acting is definitely something I
haven't tackled in the six years I've
been in LA it's something I'm scared of
but I feel like I had a really great
introduction I would love to get into
acting maybe in the future if it comes
and happens to fall in my lap again
right now I am really really thankful
that I was featured and to be a part of
it and like I said I'm not really a big
prominent face on YouTube but um I'm
really happy like more things are coming
out and I'm learning to edit my own
videos and post them and so hey I hope
it is updated into it happy mom now that
I'm kind of um injured yes love the time
yes I hope you guys all get to see me on
youtube more okay we look forward to it
well yeah that's kind of it for all of
my questions is there anything else you
kind of want to add or you want to just
put out there for fans um I really hope
you guys enjoy the when it counts
episodes we had so much fun um creating
aids being part of dancing acting making
bloopers and I thought I didn't have any
funny lines but I thank all the actions
that happen towards Ana sure that it's
like kick to the curb um I think I hope
you guys laugh cuz uh the script was
funny mm-hmm and actually living those
moments are even firing right well me it
well thank you so much for doing this
thank you so much for sitting down thank
you
you